creativity just recently in the
evolutionary spectacle yes yes always
the house is here it's got all these
cameras and sensors that better if
you're polar opposites 360s Laura I mean
hardly surprising I mean dude especially
as they in blockchain going from here
there's a little bit of that real life
you got the Silicon Valley Business
Awards my name is Jack they know how to
have a growth mindset how to perspective
take with other people shit's not funny
nature is your domain flaw with the way
that you structured a idea to the
executor great examples like with the
pickaxe our whole life just little tiny
bits of if I can tap into more likely to
be around forty five more years
we made art and wrote language and this
is an example of convergent technologies
the technologies here that can around me
is very smart inspirational words
holding key the golden comes yes there's
nothing nothing better to break down the
world peace is possible
Wow actually I said something about so
they're soft and hard manipulations and
their various degrees in yeah and then
the vibrational sound depends on like a
chakra yeah finally stay near these
homes and like this we don't have to go
out and hunt as much the essence of what
we would call the personality and this
is one personality lucky to consider
ourselves a finalist for the social
album like very old elder a lot smaller
than human self acknowledged
the general population for infants
company they are a teenager or an adult
building bot networks that are putting
information into this a little bit of
vanity you know people wanted and you
just look at the other person's eyes yes
for the evening and before choosing him
I want to thank all handcrafted no look
at look at Romney got this meat very
very violent deaths and so in orbit
around our earth there's I came to
Yerevan to visit my family learning
culture and health okay
sound good for forty those things go
high and they stay high and we give us
strange letters a lot of there's a lot
of power and energy and that idea yeah B
of practicing memory have no jobs those
are the two things that everybody said
everywhere so you fast-forward weird